[موسيقى]
من اكليل الورد مرورا بسنوات الضياع ونور
الى حريم السلطان ومحمد الفاتح والسلطان
عبد الحميد وغيرها كثير عناوين عربيه
لمسلسلات تركيه تتناول موضوعات مختلفه
اجتماعيه وتاريخيه جذبت انظار ملايين
المشاهدين في العالم العربي وصارت منافسا
قويا للاعمال الدراميه العربيه طرحه
تساؤلات عديده عن عناصر هذا النجاح
والانتشار المتنامي خلال العقدين الماضيين
ليس فقط عربيا بل ايضا عالميا فالاعمال
الدراميه التركيه تنتشر في اكثر من 150
دوله وصارت تحتل المرتبه الثانيه عالميا
بعد الاعمال الدراميه الامريكيه ويتوقع
مراقبون ان تصل عائداتها الى مليار دولار
هذا العام في قصتنا الدراما التركيه قوه
الناعمه نحاول مع منتجينا ونقادن ومثقفين
اتراك وعرب تلمس بعض من عناصر نجاح
الدراما التركيه الى اي حد صارت من اسباب
قوه تركيا الناعمه ونتسائل عن دورها في
تغيير الصوره الذهنيه للاطراك في العقليه
العربيه وكيف ادت الدراما التاريخيه الى
زياده اهتمام الجمهور العربي بالتاريخ
العثماني وتنشيط حركه الترجمه الادبيه من
التركيه الى العربيه وصولا الى التفاعل
معها بتقديم محتوى فني عنها على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي نستكمل بقيه هذه القصه
مع احمد اوبر منتج وكاتب سيناريو مسلسلات
تاريخيه تركيه ومحمد هاشم الكاتب والناقد
والسينمائي نسال ضيفينا الكريمين عن
العوامل الانتاجيه والتسويقيه الكامنه
وراء الانتشار الواسع للدراما التركيه
ومدى تاثر هذه الصناعه بالمتغيرات
السياسيه والاجتماعيه عن حدود الدعم
الحكومي لها وعن تاثيرها على الاعمال
الدراميه العربيه عن فرص التعاون والانتاج
الدرامي المشترك العربي التركي لكن بدايه
رايكم ان نشاهد القصه وبعدها نبدا
على وقع ضجيج المعارك التاريخيه وترقب
المؤامرات التي يواجهها السلطان عبد
الحميد تدور نقاشات في الشارع العربي فمن
الهواتف الذكيه الى المقاهي والجلسات
العائليه يجتمع ملايين المشاهدين العرب
لمتابعه المسلسلات التركيه في منافسه
واضحه للدراما العربيه على كسب قلوب
الجماهير
شاهدت الاعمال التركيه مشاهده لها علاقه
بجاذبيه اولا العمل التركي الدرامي لها
علاقه
بالاقتراب الثقافي او تجاور الثقافي في
ثقافه مشتركه
تركيا اليوم هي دوله ثانيه في تصدير
محتواها الفني بعد الولايات المتحده هناك
عده اسباب لهذا ابرزها في اعتقاد اننا
صنعنا لغه تعبير خاصه بنا مختلفه عن
منتجات هوليود لدينا اذا لغه التعبير هذه
وطريقه استخدامنا للموسيقى واسلوب سرد
القصه بتوسع اكبر وابطئ نوعا ما مع ارتفاع
جوده الانتاج اضافه الى ذلك فان القصص
التي نرويها اقرب الينا من تلك الامريكيه
فهي اكثر ارتباطا بنزيج منطقتنا خاصه في
المحيط القريب منك
الكثير من الحديث عن علاقه الدراما
التركيه بالقوه الناعمه وهذه العلاقه تاتي
من ان الامم تمثلها ثقافتها ايضا
فهذه المسلسلات بطريقه او باخرى تحدث من
يشاهدها عن تركيا فانت تصنع تصورك المعاصر
عن الاتراك وتركيا من خلال ما تراه في تلك
المسلسلات
شهد عام 2008 بدايه صعود المسلسلات
التركيه وساهمت الدبلجه في تقريب هذه
الاعمال الى المشاهد العربي لتمنح العرب
نافذه جديده للاطلال على المجتمع والثقافه
التركيه وتساهم في اعاده تشكيل صوره تركيا
في الذهنيه العربيه
صوره الاتراك في الذهنيه العربيه قديما
كانت للاسف صوره سلبيه الصوره دي استمرت
لحد فتره قريبه لحد سنوات الاخيره وطبعا
كان ده واضح يعني مصادر ده كان في المناهج
الدراسيه
الصحافه
والاعلام موضوع تغيير صوره الاتراك في
الذهنيه العربيه من الدراما لعبه الدور
الاكبر كانت اكثر من السياسه ومن الثقافه
ومن الامور كتير
وصلت هذه الفكره الى تغيير الصوره النمطيه
للمجتمع التركي من خلال المسلسلات التي
رات فيها الجانب التطور والجانب الحديث في
اظهار الصوره المشرقه للمجتمع التركي
اضافه الى انه قسم من مسلسلات الاجتماعيه
التي تظهر الجانب الاجتماعي والثقافي في
هذه الامور اعتمدوا في تصويرها على الجانب
الطبيعي في الاماكن السياحيه الطبيعيه
التي تظهر الجماليه التركيه
فتره هديك المسلسلات التركيه كانت منتشره
كثير على المستوى العالم العربي وتحديدا
على الاردن كان في شغف كبير بالزباين
والمواطنين الاردنيين انهم يحضروا هاي
المسلسلات بالوقت اللي انا فكرت افتح فيه
مطعم فالمسلسلات التركيه اللي كانت تبث
على القنوات الفضائيه بصوره عامه هي اللي
ساعدت في انه المطعم تبعنا ينجح لانه
ببساطه لما تحط منتج تركي بصوره عامه مع
وجود هذا الاعلام والزخم الاعلامي المواطن
شبع وصار عنده شغف انه يقبل على اي شيء
منتج تركي
لما نرجع الى اوائل ظهور المسلسلات
التركيه على شاشات العربيه نحكي اكثر على
شاشات التونسيه دخلوا بسياسه اسعار زهيده
جدا كانت القناه الوطنيه او بعض القنوات
الخاصه اللي كانت ملخص لها حتى قبل الثوره
كانت تقتني المسلسل بعشره دولار معناه
ثلاثين الحلقه او
من السياسه هذيك خلت في ضعف في ضعف
الانتاج الموجود في تونس هنا بدا الغزو
التركي لانه هناك فراغ شكل وصول الدراما
التركيه الى الشاشات العربيه نقطه تحول في
عوائدها الاقتصاديه اذ ارتفعت عقيدات
تصدير الاعمال الدراميه في تركيا من عشره
ملايين دولار عام 2008 لتصل الى 500 مليون
دولار عام 2021
وتستحوذ على متابعه 800 مليون مشاهد في
مئه وخمسين دوله حول العالم ما مهد لجني
المزيد من الفوائد للاقتصاد التركي
بطبيعه الحال فالاثر الثقافي يولد اثرا
اقتصاديا كبيرا ايضا فالقيمه المضافه
لقطاع الانتاج عاليه جدا وتاثيره غير
مباشر كبير كذلك ليس من السهل قياسه بدقه
لكننا في تركيا نتلمسه بوضوح ونعيش اثاره
من قطاع الانشاءات والعقارات الى القطاع
الصحي والمنسوجات والسياحه فهناك الكثير
من الناس يزورون تركيا لانهم شاهدوا هذه
المسلسلات ويتبع ذلك حركه اقتصاديه كبيره
كتذاكر الطيران وتكاليف الاقامه هنا واذا
ما نظرنا الى المسلسلات كمنتج فهي تمثل
25% من المسلسلات الموزعه حول العالم وهذا
رقم كبير جدا
مع انطلاق موجه المسلسلات التي تناولت
تاريخ الدوله العثمانيه عقب بث مسلسل حريم
السلطان عام 2011 تصاعد الجدل حول قدره
الدراما على مع الجه المراحل الحرجه من
تاريخ المنطقه واهدافها من وراء ذلك
بالنسبه للمسلسلات التاريخيه التي ابدع
فيها كذلك الاتراك من ناحيه الجماليه ومن
ناحيه الضخامه ومن ناحيه ضخامه الصوره وكل
هذه المسلسلات لها هدف وحيد هو التسويق
الى عظمه النظام العثماني ونظامه معناها
النظام التركي من خلال القراءه الثانيه او
القراءه الثالثه
اي مسلسل وكل مسلسل تلفزيوني تاريخي يتم
انتاجه فانه يعيد بناء التاريخ من منظور
الحاضر نحن اليوم ننظر الى ذلك التاريخ
ونفهمه من خلال تحيزاتنا الى حد ما بقدر
ما من النظره الايديولوجيه الى جانب
المعرفه التاريخيه ايضا
لذلك عندما تاخذ كل هذا بعين الاعتبار فمن
الواضح ان الرؤيه في هذه الاعمال
التاريخيه
تستلهم قراءه قوميه تركيه معاصره للتاريخ
التركي
[موسيقى]
عندما كنا ننتج مسلسل السلطان عبد الحميد
كنا نعلم ان توضيح هذه الفتره صعب جدا
وانها معقده للغايه لذا اجرينا مقابلات
كثيره مع عدد من الاساتذه المؤرخين خاصه
في مرحله الاعداد للعمل في الواقع ان
رغبتنا بعرض هذه الفتره تعود الى ان
التاريخ سلسله من الاحداث المتشابهه كما
تعلمون اي انه في كل مرحله تتكرر القضايا
ذاتها تقريبا بشخصيات جديده وفاعلين
مختلفين وبالنظر الى تشابه مرحله عبد
الحميد مع ما نعيشه اليوم نوعا ما فقد
حاولنا شرح ما حدث انذاك مع توضيح بعض
اوجه التشابه مع الواقع من خلال بعض
الاسقاطات والرسائل
[موسيقى]
الى جانب الرسائل التي حملتها الدراما
التركيه كان لها تاثيرات ثقافيه واسعه في
العالم العربي امتدت من زياده الاهتمام
بالتاريخ العثماني وتنشيط حركه الترجمه
الادبيه الى التفاعل معها بتقديم محتوى
فني على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]
لما صورت انشوده ارطغرل نزلتها طبعا
تعليقات الناس وصاروا يعملوا منشنات
للممثلين والمخرج
فظمت من بعدها انه من نفس الممثلين في
مسلسل ارطغرل
والمؤسس عثمان
لقيتهم شاركوا الفيديو عندهم على صفحتهم
وعلقوا على الاشي ومن بعدها
اختلطت فيهم اكثر وتعرفت عليهم اكثر
الفلسطينيين لما يحضروا مسلسل ارطغرل بكون
اشي مختلف ليش لانه فلسطين تحت احتلال وفي
مسلسل ارطغرل بنشوف انه كانت تتار المغول
حاول يحتل تركيا
الصليبيين كذلك الامر
اكيد طبعا بلاقي عمل مشترك
بعد عرض مسلسل السلطان عبد الحميد
وانتشاره بشكل كبير في العالم العربي
فكرنا في ترجمه روايه عنه
فلقينا روايه بصفها النقاد الاتراك بانها
وثيقه حياديه عن المرحله الحرجه في عصر
الدوله العثمانيه في اخر فتره السلطان عبد
الحميد
وترجمنا روايه ايام السلطان عبد الحميد
الاخيره للروائي ناهد صدري اوريك لكن ردود
الافعال عنها كانت كمان من يحب ويدافع عن
السلطان عبد الحميد راى ان الروائي او
الروايه تشوه صورته ومن هم ضد عبد الحميد
راوا انه الروايه تشوه الجمعيه الاتحاد
والترقي وللاسف نحن دائما نقع في هذه
الثنائيه الخاطئه تماما في تناول التاريخ
عن انقسام الحاصل في المجتمع العربي حول
القضايا التاريخيه والسياسيه المعاصره
التي تناولتها الدراما التركيه اثارت هذه
الاعمال الدراميه جدلا واسعا بين من يرى
انها تعبر عن وجهات نظر ثقافيه وتاريخيه
ومن يرى انها تخدم توجهات سياسيه حكوميه
قراءه المسلسلات التركيه اليوم لا يجب ان
تكون منفصله عن السياسه السياسه الناعمه
التي انتهجها
الحاكم التركي
منذ اكثر من 19 سنه لانه المسلسلات هي
عنصر هام وكبير اليوم في سياسات التركيه
تجاه العالم العربي
الدراما التركيه خلقت في العالم العربي ما
يمكن تسميته الان بالهواء العثماني يعني
اصبح انه في بعض العرب مثلا مع تدخل تركيا
السياسي في سوريا في العراق في في ليبيا
في اكثر من من بلد عربي
الدراما مهدت اكثر من
الخطابات السياسيه
ويعني يعني فعلت ما لم يفعله ما لم يستطع
السياسي ان يفعله الدراما لا يمكن ان تقلب
الطاسه وتجعل صوره
الامريكي جميلا في وجه الهند الاحمر
قصه انها تركيا تتمكنت من الحضور السياسي
في بعض البلدان العربيه الاذور الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي والسياسي حركتها السياسيه داخل
هذا الاقليم كيف كيف فعلتها كيف عملت
عليها كيف استطاعت من خلالها ان تجذب جزء
من الجمهور العربي وتكرس
اعلامها لخدمته يمكن صاغت مفهوم جمالي في
هذا السياق اما انها صاغت مفهوما سياسيا
لا اعتقد ذلك
على حد علمي كل المسلسلات التركيه تقريبا
تصمم اولا للسوق المحليه ويجب ان تحقق
النجاح داخل تركيا قبل ان تصدر الى الخارج
في السنوات العشر الماضيه بعض المسلسلات
يتم انتاجها مع الاخذ بعين الاعتبار انها
ستصدر الى بلدان مختلفه رغم انها ليست
مشروعا حكوميا بالضروره ورغم انه لا يتم
التلاعب بها من قبل الوكالات الحكوميه يجب
ان نفهم هذا على انه سلوك لا ارادي ففي
اذهان المنتجين وكتاب السيناريو ومخرجي
المسلسلات التلفزيونيه هم يعلمون ان
مسلسلاتهم ستعرض في العديد من البلدان
وبالتالي يضمون ذلك الى الخلطه
ويفكرون به اثناء انتاج المسلسل
مع ازدياد اعداد المتابعين العرب تحولت
الدراما التركيه الى منافس قوي ما شكل
تحديات عديده امام الدراما العربيه سواء
في اختيار الموضوعات التي تعالجها او حجم
الميزانيات والمستوى الفني الذي تقدمه
زياده عرض المسلسلات التركيه على قنواتنا
العربيه
ودائما نحب نرجع للاكثر الى تونس لها عديد
من السلبيات لانه
تنقص او تنقص كثيرا من عمليه الابداع
الابداع في الانتاج التونسي الذي
لا نشاهده الا في شهر رمضان
المعظم وكل المسلسلات التركيه ليست
بالتثقيفيه لما يعني لا يمكن ان نعتبر
اليوم المسلسل التركي
كمنتوج تثقيفي يساعد في نهضه العقل او
نهضه الفكر للمشاهد
للمشاهد التونسي المشاهد العربي بصفه بصفه
عامه العرب عندما يتحدث عن ان الدراما
التركيه السياسيه تنافسهم تنافس من لا
يوجد دراما موجهه لتعزيز الهويه العربيه
للاهتمام بالقضاء القوميه العربيه للتفاعل
مع الواقع الانساني والثقافي والاجتماعي
والاقتصاد العربي
الدول العربيه
تعتمد في انتاجها على على المستثمر او
المنتج الفردي
ولا تدعم باعتبار انه هذا يشكل على
الميزانيه الدوله واكسل لراما التركيه
التي اعتمدت الدوله في مساندتها وفي دعمها
في اظهار الجانب الجمالي لتركيا وفي ايصال
فكره معينه وهذا كان هو مغزى لدى الحكومه
التركيه في ايصال هذا هذه المواضيع الى
الناس جميعا
[موسيقى]
اصل في الواقع لا يمكننا القول بوجود مخطط
كبير لهذا الموضوع بل يجب شكر القطاع
الخاص على هذا النجاح فقد وصلت صناعه
التليفزيون وسينما التركيه الى ما هي عليه
اليوم بجهودها الخاصه بالطبع الدوله
ووزاره الثقافه تمد يد العون في صناعه
المسلسلات بمقدار ما يسد الرمق لكن
انجازات المنتجين انفسهم هي التي اوصلتهم
الى المراتب العالميه تعد المنتجات
الثقافيه مهمه حقا باعتبارها قوه ناعره
وهذه منتجات ثقافيه وليست منتجا سياسيا
[موسيقى]
على الرغم من ان لدينا الكثير من المشاكل
والصراعات في عصرنا هذا الا ان تشاركنا في
عناصر الثقافه الشعبيه ومتابعه المسلسلات
التركيه يجعلنا نشعر باننا اقرب الى بعضنا
البعض اكثر من ذي قبل
تخيل قبل اربعين عاما لم يكن التلفزيون
منتشرا لدى الجميع انذاك ولم تكن الاعمال
التركيه تعرض في العالم العربي ولا
الاعمال العربيه تعرض في العالم التركي
كذلك اما الان فهناك تغير كبير في مدى
فهمنا لبعضنا البعض وعلى مستويات متعدده
يوما بعد يوم ترتفع وتيره الانتاج الدرامي
التركي وتنمو شريحه متابعي بينما يزداد
الجدل حوله في منطقه يبدو واقعها اكثر
صخبا وتعقيدا من اي مسلسل درامي
[موسيقى]
نرحب بكم مشاهدينا الكرام وبضيفينا
الكريمين من اسطنبول السيد احمد اوكر منتج
وكاتب سيناريو ومسلسلات تاريخيه تركيه ومن
القاهره سيد محمد هاشم الكاتب والناقد
السينمائي لعلنا نبدا معك سيد احمد
ونتساءل حقيقه في تقديرك عن العوامل
والاليات الانتاجيه او حتى التسويقيه التي
منحت لادراما التركيه هذه المكانه
والانتشار عالميا
بما نحن نعرف كيف نسرد القصه منذ قرن ونصف
القرن
قبل كل شيء
يجب علينا ان نعرف كالتالي ان
في العالم العربي
وفي الجغرافيا العربيه او في البلقان في
دول البلقان
هذه الحدود ما بين الدول
الحدود السياسيه هذه الحدود ليست حدودا في
القلب ليست حدودا حقيقيه هي حدود
لم يتم رسمها من قبل البشر من قبل
المواطنين
هذه الحدود لم تكن موجوده قبل الحرب
العالميه الاولى العراق لم تكن بعيده عن
الكويت والكويت لم تكن بعيد عن السعوديه
مثلا وسوريا لم تكن بعيده عن تركيا نحن
ابناء نفس نفس العاطفه نحن ابناء نفس
البلد حكايته هي نفس حكايه المواطن العربي
ما الفرق الفرق بان
التقنيات في تركيا تطورت تطورت بالاستناد
للماضي كما قلت لكم نحن
لدينا تقاليد متجفره في السينما وفي
المسرح
نحن لدينا تجربه 150 عاما مثلا لكن اخوتنا
واشقاؤنا في العالم العربي هنالك من
يقومون بالمسلسلات منذ عشرين عاما فقط
ولهذا فان ما نقوم به
اتفوق ترى فعلا في التقنيه دعني اتحول الى
ضيفنا الكريم من القاهره سيد محمد هاشم
يعني باعتقادك ما اهم العناصر الفنيه التي
منحت الدراما التركيه بالفعل هذه المكانه
لتصل المرتبه الثانيه عالميا وهل هي فعلا
فقط الجانب التقني والفني الذي اشار اليه
ضيفنا الكريم من اسطنبول ام ان هناك عوامل
اخرى ساهمت في ان تصل الدراما التركيه الى
هذه المرتبه عالميا لكن ايضا الى كل
البيوت العربيه التي كانت في وقت من
الاوقات وعلى امتداد عقود تتصدرها الدراما
المصريه دراما السوريه في وقت ايضا اخر
اولا شكرا على الاستضافه في برنامج
للبرنامج القصه بقيه وشكرا للشهاده
الحضوره اهلا بك العوامل كثيره اولا ناخذ
نبتدي نناقش على المستوى العالمي بالنسبه
للمستوى العالمي الدراما التركيه بهرت
المشاهد الغربي والاوروبي الامريكي في
امريكا اللاتينيه
بمجتمع جديد بثقافه جديده
بحكايات جديده بخلفيه تاريخيه بمناظر
طبيعيه باداء تمثيلي وتقني رفيع جدا مما
تشكل نوع من انواع
البريق غير الموجود دايما المشاهد بيحب
الدراما تكون جديده وعنده دايما رغبه في
انه يشوف الجديد والمغاير ثقافات المغايره
الى اخره اما بالنسبه لو جينا نتكلم على
المواطن في العالم العربي وايه اسباب
انتشار المسلسلات التركيه وسيرتها فهنلاقي
عوامل عديده جدا عوامل بتبدا بان زي ما
تفضل في التقرير وتقال ان من حوالي قرنين
كانت الدراما المصريه السوريه هي اللي
تقريبا السيده وطاغيه الى ان بدات هذه
الدراما تخفت لاسباب انتاجيه اقتصاديه لها
علاقه بالثوره كما في سوريا او في مصر او
غيره فابتدى الانتاج الدرامي المصري
والسوري وغيره ابتدى يقل من هنا ابتديت
الدراما التركيه تدخل تدريجيا ابتدت تحظر
بقدر من الاجبال لدى الجمهور العربي ابتدا
يشوف صوره مختلفه تقنيه تقترب من تقنيات
السينما ممثلين على قدر هائل من
الاحترافيه على قدر كبير من الوسامه في
توظيف للاماكن التاريخيه للاماكن في تركيا
في اسطنبول في انقره في غيره لقى ان في
شيء مختلف موجود عن الدراما اللي ظل
العقود يشاهدها عنده في المنطقه موجوده في
الدراما التركيه ابتدى يشوف ان في قصص حب
انسانيه يشوف ان في نوع من انواع التنوع
اللي موجود سواء التاريخي
كثيره اعوامل كثيره
نقدر نقول كمان ان الاسهم في هذه العوامل
الخلفيه التاريخيه المشتركه ان تشابه
الاسماء تشابه بعض المفردات العربيه
من ان كل هذه المناطق في الواقع هي قريبه
وتركيا ليست بعيده عن العالم العربي ولا
العالم الاسلامي دعم يتحول مره اخرى للسيد
احمد
ونتساءل حقيقه سيد احمد السوق العربيه ما
الذي تمثله بالنسبه للدراما التركيه
انتشارها عالميا نعم لكنها باتت تدخل
البيوت العربيه بشكل كبير ونتساءل عما
تمثله ربما السوق التركيه من ناحيه
الارقام
عفوا السوق العربيه من ناحيه الارقام
للدراما التركيه
بالتاكيد بالتاكيد
كل العالم مهم بالنسبه لنا لكن لكن
الجغرافيا العربيه مهمه جدا هي هي جغرافيه
القلب عندنا جغرافيه العاطفه
لماذا لاننا نحن ابناء الدين الواحد ونحن
منتسبون لنفس الثقافه
وفرق واحد فقط بان
نحن قد يكون وجهتنا نحو اوروبا فقط لكن
لكن نحن اساسا قادمون من وسط اسيا نحن
ابناء وسط اسيا ولهذا نحن اغنياء ثقافيا
بثقافه عربيه وثقافه اسيويه ومع وجهه
اوروبيه وكما قلت لكم
انا لا افهم لماذا نحن نحتاج الى جواز
السفر عندما نذهب الى فلسطين او الى
الحجاز من اجل الحجاز هذه بلادنا هذه
اخوتنا هؤلاء اخواننا جميل ما تقول ولكن
ذلك موضوع اخر قد ربما نقوم بها في حلقه
اخرى ونقاش اخر لكن سؤالي حقيقه عما تمثله
السوق العربيه بالنسبه لادراما التركيه من
ناحيه الارقام الى اي مدى فعلا
السوق العربيه
تشكل ربما رقما كبيرا بالنسبه للدراما
التركيه ما الذي تشكله بالنسبه لكم كارقام
نقدر نقول ان خلال السنوات
2008 2009 من بعد مسلسل نور وحريم السلطان
الى اخره ابتدت الدراما التركيه تطور في
نفسها لان دراما التركيه لم تبدا قويه
بالشكل المعهود عليه الان ابتدت تطور
انتاجيا واخراجيا فابتدى يبقى فيه سخاء في
التكاليف فابتدت الساعه التكلفه الانتاج
الحلقه والانتاج المسلسل اجمالا ابتدى
يطغى بعد ما كانت الحلقه مثلا بتتكلم في
500 دولار اشتريت الحركه تتكلف الان
50,000 دولار وفي حلقه من حلقات اعتقد
ارطغرل يعني شيء من هذا القبيل تجاوزت
الخمسه مليون دولار وبالتالي اي اي قناه
او اي سوق عربي يقدر يشتري مثل هذه
التكلفه ومن هنا نقدر نقول ان اه في اقبال
على الدراما التركيه لكن الاقبال او دفع
مبالغ طائله في هذه الدراما لا اعتقد اول
مربوط الخاص بالنسبه للاصوات رغم انها في
البدايات سمعنا للنقد التونسي سيد لطيف
اشار الى ان بعض المسلسلات في بدايات
انتشاره في العالم العربي كانت تباع
للتلفزيونات المحليه بسعر عشره الاف دولار
لثلاثين حلقه كيف ترى في هذه الاستراتيجيه
هل كانت ربما سوق جديده تريد ان تنتشر
فيها ام ماذا
اولا هو زي ما ذكر في التقرير وزي ما ذكر
استاذ احمد الدراما التركيه بالاساس هي
منتجه للداخل التركي الممول بعكس الاعمال
التاريخيه التركيه زي ارطغرل او السلطان
عثمان او غيره من المسلسلات التاريخيه دي
اعتقد انها موجهه للعالم اجمع وللعالم
العربي لكن الاعمال الرومانسيه او الاعمال
الدراميه او اعمال الجريمه او غيره وهي
موجهه بالاساس داخل المجتمع التركي ودليل
الدليل على هذا ان بعض الاعمال لم تنجح
فتم ايقافها اثناء التصوير لعدم المردود
المادي الخاص بها فبالتالي المنتج التركي
عينه بالاساس على تسويق وبيع المنتجه
الدرامي داخل تركيا ومن ثم توزيعه بعد ذلك
عالميا او عربيا من هنا بيتم حساب التكلفه
او ضخ الاموال او الاستمرار في الانتاج او
توسيع الدراما وعمل مواسم للمسلسل او
ايقافه بعد حتى خمس حلقات او سبع حلقات
فالموضوع هنا اقتصادي بحت بالنسبه للدراما
التركيه تحول يا سيد
في راي احد ضيوفي في الميناء الليله من ان
الافلام التركيه تنتج بالاساس للسوق
المحليه سؤالنا حقيقه ان كانت كذلك كيف
اثرت ربما المتغيرات الاجتماعيه وحتى
السياسيه في تركيا خلال العقدين الماضيين
على هذه الاعمال
الدراميه التركيه سواء في المضامين
واساليب الانتاج ايضا
قبل كل شيء
[موسيقى]
ايضا منتجات اخرى تركيه يتم تصويرها
للخارج ايضا تطورت ان كان هنالك نهوض بشكل
عام في اي دوله كل المجالات تتطور
وايضا المسلسلات التركيه والدرامه التركيه
تطورت نحن افلامنا ودراما التركيه نحن لا
نفكر بان تهتم بنا الدول الاخرى نحن نقوم
بالانتاج من اجلنا نحن من اجل سوقنا نحن
ما ينفع في السوق التركيه ينفع في الخارج
ايضا المسلسلات التركيه عندما تباع للخارج
الناس في الخارج
لا
يعرفون بان هذه المسلسلات نجحت في تركيا
ايضا من يشترون هذه المسلسلات ينظرون الى
الريتنج الى المبيعات في تركيا
ليس فقط ليس فقط الدراما التركيه جيده
المتابع التركي والمشاهد التركي ايضا
ومتابع جيد
يعني انت تشير لي نقطه مهمه لكن في الواقع
المتحدثون الاتراك في فيلم الليله تحدثوا
ايضا بان
الجهات الحكوميه لا تتدخل ايضا في توجيه
هذه الاعمال الفنيه الواقع يشير الى ان
الانتشار لهذه الاعمال بدا قرابه سنه 2008
اي بعد تقريبا ست سنوات من وصول حزب
العداله والتنميه الى حكم البلاد مضامين
بعضها هذه الافلام
والدراما تحديدا يقول بعد انه يتفق مع
توجهات حزب العداله والتنميه الى اي حد
اعتقادك الحكومه تدعم فعلا منتجي هذه
الاعمال نتحدث تحديدا عن الاعمال
التاريخيه التي لقيت صدا كبيرا في العالم
العربي ايجابيا لكن اثارت الجدل ايضا لدى
البعض الاخر
الحكومه التركيه لا تؤثر في اعمال
الدراميه التركيه
نحن ثقافتنا
ثقافتنا وتاريخنا وادبياتنا هي التي
تجعلنا ننتج مثل هذه الامور اذا كنتم
تتحدثون عن تدخل حكومي فانا اقول لكم بان
التدخل الحكومي غير موجود لا
مسلسل مسلسل بارباروس نحن نتحدث عن بربروس
وانقاذهم الاخوه بربروسيهم للجزائر عندما
نتحدث عن عبد الحميد عن السلطان عبد
الحميد الم يجادل من اجل فلسطين الحكومه
لا تملي علينا ان نقول لا التاريخ هو من
يملي علينا ما نقول
للتاريخ يقول البعض سيد احمد انه لديه عده
روايات سمعنا ذلك في شهاده احد الضيوف كل
يراه من منظوره وهنا ربما مصدر الجدل الذي
احدثته بعض هذه الاعمال التاريخيه من ان
هذه الاعمال تروج للاجنده السياسيه للحزب
الحاكم في تركيا
وتقدم عاده رسائل سياسيه هدفها تاكيد ربما
تفوق الاتراك في العالم العربي
والاسلامي
لا لا الاتراك فعلا الاتراك اكثر عدلا
الاتراك اكثر بطوله من هذه المسلسلات هذه
المسلسلات تعكس القصه الحقيقيه هذه ليست
فكشن هذه ليست خيال
اعود للسيد احمد او محمد هاشم من القاهره
ونتساءل حقيقه عن هذه هذا الجدل الذي
احدثته بعض المسلسلات التركيه يعني ربما
كانت هناك محاوله دراميه ان صح التعبير
للرد على المسلسلات التركيه التاريخيه ظهر
مثلا مسلسل ممالك النار الذي يحكي قصه
انهيار الدوله المملوكيه في مصر والشام
امام الدوله العثمانيه هذا ربما يطرح
تساؤلات هل نحن امام روايه تقدمها الدراما
التركيه تريد الدراما العربيه ان تقدم
ايضا روايتها رغم ضخامه اله هذه الدراما
التركيه مما لا يخلق ولا يقدم توازنا باي
شكل من الاشكال للطرفين
طيب خلينا نرجع نناقش النقطه اللي كانت
مطروحه مع السيد احمد وخلينا ناكد ان على
سبيل المثال ودي وقائع وحقائق ثابته
ومنشوره ان وقت عرض في مسلسل حريم السلطان
اثار الكفيل من الجدل داخل تركيا وشاكت
وادانا وبرلمان الى اخره
ومن ثم كان في المقابل لقيامه المسلسل
الرائع قيامه ارطغرل وحتى الرئيس التركي
بنفسه زار موقع التصوير المسلسل واثنى
عليه ومن هنا نقدر نقول ان احيانا مش
هنقدر نقول بشكل كامل احيانا ان الدوله
التركيه فيما يتعلق بالمسلسل العمال
التاريخيه لا نتحدث عن الاعمال الرومانسيه
او غيرها من الاعمال الاجتماعيه او او
غيره احيانا بيكون فيه هل بغرض تمرير
رساله او لا هل بغرض تصحيح سوره
التركي في الاذهان العربيه او الاذهان
العالميه هل بغرض
تنظيم التاريخ التركي وابطاله فهذا من هذا
المنظور ممكن نقول ان اوكي من حقق اي دوله
في العالم انها تفخر بقادتها بتاريخها
وتشوفها بالشكل اللي هي تقدر انها تقدمه
للناس او تصيغه للناس هل هذا يتفق مع
الحقيقه او لا دي قضيه اخرى ممكن نناقشها
يعني باستفاضه لكن الحكومه التركيه في
احيانا بتشارك بالتمويل لكن غيره من
الاعمال لا لا تشارك وخلينا كمان لا ننسى
ان وزاره الثقافه والسياحه اسمها كده في
تركيا بمعنى ان حتى الاعمال العاديه هي
ترويج للسياحه وتركيا بشكل عام مش لرسائل
او مضامين سياسيه او تاريخيه او
رجوعا الى مسلسل ممالك النار او غيره من
المسلسلات التاريخيه احنا نقدر نقول ان
يمكن الميزه لا خلقتها الدراما التاريخيه
التركيه انها حفظت حفزت
المنتج المصري او
الدراما المصريه ان احنا كمان
والدول هتبتدي انها تضخ استثمارات لان في
النهايه احنا بننسى ان صناعه السينما او
الدراما او اي صناعه فنيه هي في الاخر
صناعه صناعه يعني مكسب وربح اي دوله او اي
تاجر او اي ممول لو لقى ان في مردود هينتج
ما عندوش اي مشكله حتى لو هيبص رسائل
سياسيه او غير رسائل او رسائل رومانسيه مش
فارقه مع المهم بالنسبه له هو المردود
والمكسب والربح هو ده اللي بيحكم المعادله
في النهايه زي محمد هشام نتساءل معك حقيقه
هذه
الجماهيريه ان صح التعبير للدراما التركيه
على مستوى العالم العربي يعني في كل مكان
كيف اثرت على الاعمال الدراميه العربيه
باعتقادك في اي اتجاه تحدث بانها تحفز
لكنها في المقابل الم تستغل فراغا هو
موجود في نهايه الامر
هو كما ذكرت في بدايه الحديثي ان الفراغ
لم تخلق هذا
الفراغ لم تخلقوا الدراما التركيه بل
خلقوا السوق العربي نفسه للعوامل معينه
ادت لضعف السوق العربي فبالتالي ابتدت
الدراما تخش لكن الان في ظني ان مع حضور
الدراما المصريه السنه دي مثلا في رمضان
30 مسلسل لاول مره ومع انتعاش
الانتاجون يعني جوده تذكر ومن هنا ربما
سؤال ما الذي ادى ربما الى تراجع الدراما
المصريه التي كانت في اوجع عطائها يعني
لسنوات عديده وكانت الاكثر انتشارا في
العالم العربي مثلا هل هي الرقابه هل هي
السيطره الحكوميه لها دور ماء ام ان ربما
هناك غياب في الالهام في القصص الفنيه
المبدعه امام كميه الجمال والابتكار الذي
تحدثت عنه منذ البدايه التي تقدمه الدراما
التركيه
لن اكون مبالغا لو قلت ان
العوامل لا نهائيه بدايه من اختفاء كتاب
الدراما العظام امثال اسامه انور عكاشه
وغيره من على الساحه المصريه
بسبب التوقف الى
ضعف الامكانيات الماديه والانتاجيه
والتمويليه للمسلسلات الى دخول دور
الاعلانات ايضا والمنتج الاعلاني اللي هو
بات يطلب متطلبات عايز مسلسلات بشكل معين
بحجم معين بطول معين بممثلين معينين ايضا
دور الممثلين مشكله كانت مشكله كبيره
الممثل كان احيانا اجره بيوصل ل 70 او 75%
من ميزانيه المسلسل كامل وبالتالي المسلسل
بينتج بالربع الباقي فده ياثر على جوده
العمل اثر على الكتابه اثر على التمثيل
اثر على كل شيء فكان في ضعف في الكتابه
ضعف في التمثيل ضعف في في اللوكيشن نفسها
او اللي نقدر نقول اماكن التصوير اللي
كانت بتتصور جوه استوديو عشان توفير
النفقات
في الازياء الازياء بالنسبه لنا كانت لا
تذكر يعني شيء يعني يعتبر مخزي ينجاز
التعبير بمقارنه بالدراما التركيه
اماكن التصوير الموسيقى التصويريه نفسها
حتى الموسيقى التصويريه في الدراما
التركيه ساحره لكن احنا ابتدينا خلال
الفتره اللي فاتت السنوات بدايه من 2017
ابتدت الاعمال المصريه والعربيه ابتدت
تلتفت لجوده الصوره لجوده الكتابه للاجزاء
لتحازل الدراما التركيه للخروج الى
الاماكن التاريخيه او للطبيعه عشان تصور
التدوير التفت لجوده للتمثيل للموسيقى
التصويريه الازياء ابتدت تكون فارقه
شفناها نروح للشغل التاريخي لا ابتدت
الدراما حصل نوع من انواع المنافسه حفزت
الدراما العربيه على انها تطور من نفسها
في النهايه كي تجذب الجمهور العربي عشان
تخلي الجمهور العربي يقدر يتابعها
تحول للسيد احمد اوكار حقيقه يعني ان كان
الاتراك لديهم
هذا الانتماء للامه الاسلاميه
والشعور الجميل بمشاعر الجوار والقرب منها
هل يمكن ان نتوقع مثلا ان تكون هناك دراما
مشتركه بين الطرفين اي نوع من التعاون بين
الطرفين ربما ليشكل رافدا ان المنافسه
ربما قد تمنع ذلك لان في نهايه الامر
موضوع الصنعه وهو رغبه في الربح في نهايه
الامر ودراما التركيه تريد ان تبقى محتله
هذه المراتب ليس في العالم العربي فقط لكن
في العالم ايضا وهذا من حقها
بالتاكيد
هنالك اعمال مشتركه في السنوات الخمس
الاخيره
هنالك اعمال مشتركه عربيه وتركيه
انا مثلا
المخرجة المخرج الذي اتعامل معه ذهب الى
السعوديه وانتج مسلسلا تاريخا مشتركا
مثلا
هنالك قصه قصه اسمها العروس من اسطنبوليه
عولجت في لبنان واصبحت العروس البيروتيه
بالتاكيد هنالك معالجات مشتركه هنالك اخوه
لنا واصدقائنا ينتجون اعمالا مشتركه معنا
منذ خمس سنوات اخيره ونحن نريد مثل هذا
التعاون كما قلت لكم ثقافتنا واحده
جغرافيه واحده
نتساءل حقيقه الى اين ستمضي هذه الدراما
التركيه في ظل هذا الانتشار الواسعه
للامكانيات الكبيره الفنيات العاليه وحتى
الدعم والقبول الذي تلقاه في مختلف دول
العالم نتحدث على امريكا نتحدث على اوروبا
نتحدث على اسيا كما ذكرت وليس الشرق
الاوسط العربي والاسلامي بعيدا عن هذه
المنطقه الهدف هو الوصول بقيمه صادرات
تركيا في الواقع وفق ما اعلن عنه اتراك هو
مليار دولار خلال العام الحالي على ماذا
يمكن التعويل ربما لزياده حجم الصادرات من
اعمال الدراميه
قطاع المسلسلات التركيه قبل كل شيء
هو تطور داخل تركيا وهو يريد ان يرفع نفسه
ويريد وهذا القطاع يريد ان يتطور داخل
تركيا يريد ان يتطور في العالم ايضا نحن
نريد ان
نصنع مسلسلا عاليا المستوى من اجلنا نحن
وبعد ذلك نبيعه في العالم وهذه مسيره
مستمره وهذه مسيره ستستمر ايضا وسيزداد
انتاجنا وسياد صناعتنا
قادره بالفعل ان ترتقي بنفسها حتى تصبح
ربما منافسه لادراما التركيه او على الاقل
تاخذ مكانتها
بدايه في العالم العربي ثم ربما الانتشار
العالمي لما لا
طيب خلينا نرجع بس شويه
للسينما خلال فتره الستينات والسبعينات
وعايز اقول ان السينما المصريه تحديدا
والسينما التركيه كان في هناك تعاون مشترك
ما بينهم على سبيل المثال الممثل الكبير
فريد شوقي قام بطوله تقريبا ست افلام في
تركيا وكان بتصدر الافيشاد وكان بالدبلج
حوارات وكان موجود هناك فاذا التعاون
العربي التركي موجود بسبب السينما والان
بعد عروس
بيروت اللي هو اقتبس عن اسطنبول وفي
مسلسلين اخر الاخرين لبنانيين ابتدا يتم
اقتباسهم او تقريبا جاره تنفذهم فاذا
الموضوع ممتد لكن في النهايه هو هيخضع
لايه هيخضع للسوق وللعرض والطلب لكن
التساؤل اللي بيدور في في ذهني فعلا احنا
نحن تبنينا الدراما التركيه لاسباب عديده
وقمنا بدبلجتها وكومنا في الوطن العربي هل
في يوم من الايام ستقوم
خلينا نقول المنتج وليس الحكومه التركيه
او وزاره السياحه والثقافه التركيه خلينا
نقول المنتج التركي هل في يوم من الايام
حتى ياتي دور المنتج التركي الذي يقوم
بانتقاء مسلسلات عربيه سواء قديمه من او
حديثه ويقوم دبلجتها للمشاهد التركي ام هو
حوار من طرف واحد فقط يملي فيه القوي دوره
على
الضعيف او نقدر نقول الاقل فنيه ده سؤال
مطروح من جهه تانيه انا قرات ان الامارات
والسعوديه واللبنان وغيره من الدوله ابتدت
بسبب تسهيلات معينه يتقنها الدوله التركيه
للانتقال للتصوير هناك في الاستديوهات
والاستعانه بممثلين ومخرجين وفنيين
الاتراك فهل في وقت من الاوقات هيبتدي
نحصل بالنسبه لنا نفس الاستعانه بنفس
الدور هل الجهه التركيه على
استعداد للقيام بنفس هذا الدور ام لا دي
من ضمن
اسئله كتيره بيتم طرحها خاصه في ظل
التاريخ والعلاقات المشتركه ما بين
دول المنطقه العربيه
الى اي مدى سيصل هذا
التعاون المشترك ده في النهايه زي ما
بنقول هو وافق على المنتج التركي او او
الممول وفي نفس الوقت العلاقات لان في
النهايه برده الفن محكوم بعلاقات ثقافيه
وجغرافيه وتاريخيه وسياسيه طبعا في المقام
الاول والاخير بالظبط
انتهى تماما اشكرك جزيل الشكر السيد محمد
هاشم الكاتب والنقل السينمائي كنت معنا من
القاهره كما اشكر جزيل الشكر السيد احمد
المنتج والكاتب للسيناريوهات في مسلسلات
تاريخيه تركيه كنت معنا من اسطنبول ختموا
حلقتنا هذه من برنامج القصه الباقيه نعود
باذن الله مع بقيه لقصه جديده الاسبوع
القادم
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]